cuando me pregunto qué es la belleza se
me vienen varias respuestas la belleza
está en los ojos de quien la mira en
gustos y colores no discuten los
doctores porque la belleza es algo
subjetivo y depende de muchos factores
yo todos los días me levanto convencida
que soy linda y un día antes de salir de
casa mi familia me pregunta si no será
mejor cubrir mi prótesis para que no se
note lo entiendo en su afán de
protección no quieren que esas miradas
indiscretas te molesten porque siempre
el verte diferente es extraño es
diferente
será así porque de pronto uno se ve como
un personaje de una película de ciencia
ficción y bueno mayo con esta linda
prótesis que tengo
soy contadora y auditora con 24 años de
experiencia y hace 8 años me
diagnosticaron un sarcoma en mi tobillo
izquierdo
la decisión de amputar fue una de las
mejores decisiones que tome para
erradicar el cáncer y seguir con vida y
yo que pensaba que lo más difícil y
largo en la vida era sacar un título
universitario y conseguir un buen
trabajo pero la vida me puso obstáculos
obstáculos que me enseñaron a reinventar
concluido el tratamiento luego de siete
meses de quimioterapia tuve que volver a
trabajar aceptar mi nueva condición
adaptarme a caminar a prótesis seguir
pendiente de todos los controles médicos
y todo esto esperando siempre que el
cáncer no vuelva
ahora soy parte de una ong internacional
de amputados ellos le pusieron pies a
mis sueños y donan prótesis a personas
que no tienen acceso a ellas y uno de
sus eventos de recaudación de fondos es
escalar montañas
yo nunca había hecho ejercicio antes del
cáncer y escalar una montaña aprender a
escalar se constituyó en uno desea a
veces volver a la vida es una odisea
para una persona como una amputación
como la mía es difícil escalar pero me
esforcé y empecé a descubrir cosas de mí
misma que no conocía la fundación a ver
tu empeño y dedicación te dona una
prótesis con tecnología de esas que sólo
ves en internet y un día entrenando uno
de tus compañeros de equipo te pregunta
si por tanto esfuerzo y dedicación no
deberían pagarnos y tú le recuerdas que
es uno de los pocos afortunados que
tienen una prótesis que probablemente
tiene un costo de unos 30 mil dólares
cuando eres una persona con discapacidad
otra de las cosas que tienes que
aprender es a cultivar la paciencia
paciencia con tu nueva vida a ciencia
con tu nueva pierna y para certificar tu
condición ante el estado
para revisar investigar aprender todo lo
establecido en la ley de discapacidad es
el primer paso sacar una cita que pueden
darse en que pueden darte en un lapso de
tiempo que puede ir desde el día
siguiente al siguiente semestre existen
casos de enfermedades que no se
evidencian en el cuerpo físico como son
las enfermedades mentales y autoinmunes
que son aún más difíciles de certificar
ellos ya tienen un doctorado en
paciencia
cuando trató de ejercer mis derechos
establecidos en la ley de discapacidades
más obstáculos largas filas documentos
que siempre están más llenados de
acuerdo al criterio de quien revisa los
documentos y por último pero no menos
importante interpretaciones de la ley
que hacen las personas e instituciones
para dejarte sin ciertos beneficios
en este camino me encuentro con algunos
compañeros de este exclusivo grupo que
ni saben de la existencia de la ley de
discapacidades por lo cual no saben de
sus derechos obligaciones y beneficios a
tal punto que por los bienes o servicios
que pagan ni siquiera piden factura a su
nombre para poder recuperar impuestos
también está el caso de las empresas que
sienten una presión muy grande por
contratar porque están obligados a
contratar a personas con discapacidad
porque son colaboradores a quienes no
contratas por sus habilidades o talentos
sino por obligaciones legales
y así las personas con discapacidad
vamos aprendiendo que tenemos derechos y
a veces vamos olvidando nuestras
responsabilidades
luego de todo el dinero y tiempo que
tuve que invertir para sobrevivir y
salvar mi vida para volver a caminar
recuperar mi salud me puse a investigar
sobre la ley de discapacidades y todos
los beneficios que ahí tenemos para
poder recuperar impuestos y otros
beneficios y que nos permitan tener y
poder solventar algunos gastos porque
para eso es esta ley no en mi caso mi
prótesis y sus elementos que por su dt
por por el paso del tiempo tengo que ir
renovando ciertos ciertos elementos y
también por los innumerables controles
médicos que uno debe hacerse y también
porque no para tener calidad de vida
pero a veces no es tan sencillo como por
ejemplo cuando necesito la
recalificación de mi discapacidad tengo
que probar y jurar a los médicos que no
me va a crecer la pierna es ahí donde yo
me di cuenta que no sólo bastaba
reinventarme yo tenía que reinventar a
todos los involucrados en este ciclo de
discapacidad empezando por mí mi familia
las empresas públicas privadas y como no
también los políticos
para hacer una revolución en
discapacidades
necesitamos una transformación de raíz
eso significa dejar de vernos como
víctimas y empezar a querernos como
somos con lo que tenemos y lo que no
tenemos solo así las personas e
instituciones van a empezar a
respetarnos y apreciarlos
tenemos que con nuestro propio ejemplo
de autoaceptación ante la sociedad
y nuestro propio ejemplo de
autoaceptación ante la sociedad nos va a
permitir soñar en función de una
realidad y poder así desterrar una
fantasía
en mi caso el primer paso esencial fue
trabajar en mi autoestima es importante
que en el hogar donde exista una persona
con discapacidad le hagan sentirse como
una persona normal con la capacidad de
poder conquistar todo lo que quiera
lograr
y enseñar a amarnos con nuestras
diferencias que nos hacen únicos e
irrepetibles
lester desterrando los sobrenombres y
las burlas
no escondernos sino dejar que nos vean
porque el escondernos
solo agranda los prejuicios y los miedos
a los niños desde pequeños enseñarles
sobre la existencia de nosotros las
personas con capacidades especiales y
por último enseñar a desenvolvernos
solos y también que el entorno familiar
empiece a involucrarse en todo el manejo
de las discapacidades y en el marco
legal que existe para poder acceder a
una mejor calidad de vida porque todo
trabajando en equipo siempre sale mejor
es un gran paso hacer esto pero no es lo
único que necesitamos falta en
capacitarnos en cómo manejar nuestras
discapacidades qué talentos y
habilidades podemos tener para
adaptarnos a vivir en sociedad
que nuestras familias nos apoyen en este
proceso y también nosotros empezar a
capacitarnos en las leyes que nos
aplican
desterrar la victimización es esencial
me considero una sobreviviente porque el
cáncer me enseñó que mi fortaleza está
no en mi físico sino en mi carácter en
mi amor a la vida y en el esfuerzo que
cada día hago para ganarme el trabajo
diario
el segundo paso es hacer incidencia es
necesario que todas las leyes consideren
la realidad y el punto de vista de todos
los involucrados que van a ser
considerados en esas leyes aún recuerdo
el primer reglamento de discapacidades
que establecía que para tener acceso a
los beneficios y escritos teníamos que
acreditar un porcentaje de discapacidad
del 40 por ciento antes no existían
porcentajes de discapacidad y sabían
ustedes que una amputación como la mía
apenas representa un 32 por ciento de
discapacidad señores políticos el
trabajo de hacer leyes eso en función de
una realidad y no de un presupuesto que
se les empieza a ir de las manos y
cuando creen o modifiquen leyes piensen
en trámites menos engorrosos y
elaborados por que actualmente parecería
que quieren que desistamos del intento
el tercer paso consiste en capacitarnos
tanto personas con capacidades
especiales como empresas para poder
dialogar en un lenguaje común con un
claro ambiente de cuáles son nuestros
derechos y responsabilidades sólo así
las empresas van a empezar a conocer
nuestra manera de trabajar
el conocido gente increíble que hace un
trabajo de excelencia considerando sus
condiciones pero nadie lo nota porque no
está dentro de la norma no existen
parámetros laborales de calificación
para personas con discapacidad
y capacitar también al personal de las
instituciones públicas para que
tranquilamente nos expliquen cuáles son
los trámites o pasos para acceder a
algún proceso que necesitamos y de ser
el caso que también nos expliquen
claramente por qué no se nos otorga algo
que estamos pidiendo
para nosotras las personas con
capacidades diferentes los problemas
existen pero también las soluciones
la capacitación que trae el conocimiento
y el desterrar la victimización son una
de las herramientas que tenemos para
empezar a trabajar por un futuro mejor
nuestro y de nuestras familias
considero que en el ecuador existen
muchas instituciones que tienen todo el
presupuesto para poder emprender con
estos programas de capacitación en el
cual todos los involucrados salgamos
ganando pero la verdad no sé si esto sea
posible pero esto no debe limitar nos
simplemente cambiaríamos el escenario y
a través de una institución privada
dedicada a estos temas podemos empezar a
inspirar a personas con discapacidad y
sus familias en función de modelos
reales de esperanza para que empiecen a
soñar cambiando la victimización por
empoderamiento
necesitamos capacitar con lenguaje
sencillo a las personas y sus familias
para que se involucren en la ley de
discapacidades conozcan sus derechos
obligaciones y beneficios
también acercarnos a las empresas que
necesitan por ley contratar personal con
discapacidad conocer cuáles son sus
requerimientos a todo nivel y en función
de este censo buscar a esas personas oa
sus sustitutos y en función del tipo de
discapacidad y porcentajes armar una
base de datos para poder capacitarlos en
los servicios o labores que van a hacer
garantizando una inserción productiva
exitosa y a su vez las empresas van a
sentir que tienen un socio ideal para
cumplir con todos estos temas legales
la revolución empieza cuando uno se
acepta como es no tiene miedo de salir
de exhibirse y predique el cambio con su
vida y sus datos cuando yo ampute mi
pierna para erradicar el cáncer no
ampute mis sueños y no deje de luchar y
en este camino descubrí que no solo
quiero caminar sino correr y ahora este
año voy a hacer mi primer maratón subo
montañas y glaciares decidí que no iba
a dejar que mi tiempo se pierda añorando
lo que no tenía y empecé a soñar con lo
que podía tener en mi nueva realidad el
aceptar mi vida y el aceptarme a mí
misma está ayudando a que otras personas
también se acepten y empiecen a luchar
por sus propios sueños y en este camino
presionar a las leyes instituciones pero
sobre todo a las personas para que
cambien victimización y paternalismo por
empoderamiento señores esa es la
verdadera revolución muchas gracias
[Aplausos]